sony is ducati
here the opponent doesn't even come a little
faster wobbled
gamestar advises panther
to manage black again spanish
pretty bitter lost medicine in
the position the 25
okay that's also played more often
however
the pawn is gone for a moment because it  now
two are sagging
son joda i always played springer the
first cover that thing
jumper goes three
sets obvious i
probably have g6 draw yes of
course it also makes sense to
b 5 after five go
yes somehow that is not so nice well
ok first of all  on 10 6 covering
yes that just struck me too can
even take the runner quite bluntly with the queen
the four so that the four knights
the 47
knight offers
yes there is somehow hanging at the end something like that
again such a bad
position awful my god  can
I get variants for this
jumper the five maybe
help
runners the four
so look as stable somehow
come to a standstill here is of course
somehow shitty the position but
jump the e3 d5 my god I'm
happy because the adjustment
yeah yeah I've seen that too maybe
you can  since ma try 5
at that time jumped from 53 3
well that's a bit of relief well well
he can just do thome 1 or
something like that but is still
stupid
directly to it
yes b7 you can of course can I have
no deduction how strong is
good  what helfer ii 5 how about
tumaba 8 should absolutely
springer f5 my god well come
yes if he somehow drew 0 now
maybe makes pregnant b4 and springer the
three a year well okay that is of course
no 0 looking for
yes these six are easy
good knight e7 nothing really threatening yet
30 yes come on
man oh man oh man
so knight the three I'll be
tied hand and foot afterwards if a3 comes
and 11 7 is a problem bishop h6 god god
wonderful position wonderful position
what about knight again  back
to c six meter jumper i7 now
he quits before eight
he can also david branch comes try
where i jump 610 actually as if
he wins immediately jumper you six
jumps 11 7
i can also 21 take it then
tied up a train for a short time
cross-country skier the 6
yes he tries to play nice here
you can of course somehow understand
hey morning
we have the 5s my god
no train
designs that for a sermon hello
so I have to play it until six because
with me six of course to get out of the ten
here  going out and then he runs six
yes of course
that's uncomfortable was a terrible
party